One of the things we didn't
talk about the feature is,
I've done a fair amount
of angel investing.
So, we've seen a lot of people come
in and pitch ideas, and when you're
watching people that pitch these ideas,
there's a lot you can tell from body
language, a lot that you can tell about
how people talk about how they got into
the current area that they're in and the
problem that they want to want to solve.
And you can really feel that passion.
I think as far as growing a team
around you, as an entrepreneur or
as an investor,
you can look at the entrepreneur and
you can see, well who's helping them?
Who are their advisors?
Who are the people who
have already signed up,
maybe before there's ever any money,
before the business is formed?
And you can see as far is
to see a lot of evidence
of whether the person can
really do this or not.